I actually forgot about that incident  sebastian stan is speaking out about  co-star Tom Hiddleston's former  relationship with Taylor Swift for the  35 year old infinity war actor stopped  by watch what happens live with Andy  Cohen on Thursday and when a fan asked  what he thought of his co-stars romance  with the pop star she had an amazing  question it was one of oh and extreme  concern he admitted he had concerns at  the time I was really worried for mainly  for him  yeah he went in hard there yeah well but  you know love yeah it's quick yes hard  in case you forgot Taylor and Tom  briefly dated in the summer of 2016  after meeting at the 2016 Met Gala in  May when she was still with Calvin  Harris but by September the two had  broken up  [Music]  and it was revealed months later that  she was dating her current boyfriend Joe  Allen and I'll write your name boys only  want love if it's torture  [Music]